- Good morning Believe Nation.
It's Evan, my one word is believe,
and I believe in people more
than they believe in themselves,
and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey,
today's message is, enjoy the journey.
Over to you, Eckhart Tolle.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Talking about past
and future and excessive
emphasis on past and future in your life.
Yes, of course, you need to have ...
There's nothing wrong
with having a certain
intention on what you want to achieve,
take steps towards it,
it's part of living
here in this dimension.
You can't just say I'm never
going to plan anything anymore,
just take life as it comes.
Well, some people try to do that,
but they're not that happy
either after a while.
So then your life will get very diffused
and so to have an intention
to make a plan, perfectly fine.
Either short term plan,
like I'm going to meet
you tomorrow at 4 o'clock.
How would you ever meet
anybody if we didn't time?
And future, at a practical level,
of course it's needed.
the question is whether
future takes over your mind
being able to use it
for practical purposes
is, of course, great,
but I call that clock time, is fine,
but psychological time is when the future
takes over your mind and your entire
thought patterns are
geared only towards future,
and you treat the present moment as
either just a means to an end,
because it enables you
to get to the next one.
You're always reaching out, so to speak,
internally to the next,
yet never quite here,
always looking for some fulfillment there,
so you can never embrace
the fullness of now.
Or you make the now into even an enemy.
Some people are always unhappy,
perhaps we all know some,
one or two people like that.
- Three.
(laughs)
- Who are, wherever they are,
they are complaining
it's never quite right.
Wherever they are, or
whoever they are with,
after a little while, they're
very uncomfortable again,
and should be somewhere else.
You know the bumper sticker
you see on some cars,
there are various versions of it,
says, "I'd rather be golfing."
And then another one says,
"I'd rather be fishing."
I'd rather be this, I'd rather be there.
When I visited the
spiritual teacher Ram Dass,
who lives in Hawaii, he
has a bumper sticker ...
Oh, Ram Dass was the
person who, in the 70s,
wrote the book Be Here Now.
Anyway, he has a bumper sticker on his car
that says, "I'd rather be here now."
(audience laughs)
And then you realize
that you can actually,
you can still pursue
whatever an intention ...
Where you want to get to, a plan.
I call that, it's a bit like a journey,
your life is a journey.
You know you want to
go from here to there.
Whether you're going to
get there, we don't know.
Maybe on the way you'll
branch out to somewhere else.
But at least you have a certain direction.
It's good to have a some
direction in your life.
But while you are traveling
if your destination takes
up most of your attention
and you're continuously focusing on there,
you miss all the journey really.
You can't enjoy the journey anymore.
And most of your life is the journey.
The arriving is relatively rare.
The wedding, ahh ahh
(audience laughs)
And few more graduations, ahh ahh.
But so those moments are not the ...
Far and few between, so
the rest is the journey.
And if you can't enjoy the journey,
which is means the step
you're taking at this moment
is really the most important.
Yes, of course, you know
you're going that way,
but this step is still to be enjoyed,
because that's ultimately
your whole life consists
of the step you're taking at this moment.
There is never anything else.
- Most entrepreneurs fail, I believe,
because they don't enjoy the journey.
Because they set some
big goal for themselves,
they want to have a million dollars,
or they want to build this company,
or whatever it is that
they want to go out and do.
And they're so attached to the goal,
without the process, without the how,
without the execution on a daily basis.
I believe most entrepreneurs fail
because all they do is have a goal,
and they say, "I'm going
to do whatever it takes
to go and hit that goal."
But they don't enjoy
the whatever it takes.
And if all you're doing
is jumping from one goal
to another goal to another goal,
and never enjoying the process
or the journey along the way,
you're never going to be fulfilled.
You're never going to be happy,
you're never going to actually hit
most of those big goals
that you set for yourself.
It comes up consistently
over and over and over and over again,
in all the people that I profile,
from all walks of life,
from entrepreneurs to
singers to actors, musicians,
politicians, business
people, athletes, everyone.
You have to enjoy the grind.
And a lot of people see the
grind as a negative thing.
They see it as this just
constant hustle and work.
And if you're working on the wrong thing,
then it is a negative thing.
If you threw me into your job,
into whatever your business was,
I would probably suffocate.
In most businesses, in
most jobs, in most roles,
and I had part-time jobs
and other jobs before starting this,
I suffocated.
I hated it.
I could only force myself
to do something for so long.
You can only force
yourself to do something
that you don't enjoy for
so long before you quit.
'Cause it sucks.
Where you have to enjoy the daily process
of the work that you're doing.
Now, that becomes especially
hard for entrepreneurs
because there's a lot of crap
that we have to deal
with to build a business.
There's a lot of crap
we have to deal with,
and there's very minimal
results at the beginning,
as you're just getting started,
as you're building up momentum,
there's very small results
that you're actually getting
back for your company.
So it's hard to stay motivated,
it's hard to keep going.
So not every day is going to be amazing
as an entrepreneur.
In fact you're going to
have a lot of crappy days.
You're going to have a lot of
days that just don't work out.
A lot of days that you feel like quitting.
A lot of days where you are
really hard on yourself,
really negative towards yourself,
saying that you're never going to make it.
You're going to have a lot of
those days as an entrepreneur.
The thing that gets you through
is that you still enjoy the work.
You may not enjoy everything else
around building a business,
but you enjoy the work,
you enjoy creating
whatever you're creating.
You enjoy dealing with your customers.
Whatever it is that you need
to take more responsibility
of, more ownership of,
to do more consistently.
I love making videos.
I love helping entrepreneurs.
Not every day is amazing,
in my life on my YouTube channel.
You know, we had the whole past month
of not having great audio on the videos,
and you guys gave me a
ton of flack for that.
And, you know, well deserved.
I have standards too.
And we all want to make amazing videos
for you guys on my team.
So not every day's going to be special,
not ever day's going to
be the best day ever.
But net-net, I love making
videos for you guys.
I love the work that I do.
I wouldn't want to be
doing something else.
I don't sit in my office, or sit at home,
or sit here at TDS, and thinking,
"Huh, I wish I could do this."
As soon as I get that idea,
I wish I could do something else,
I have to go out and do it.
It means what I'm doing is wrong.
It means I have to cut something
that I'm doing right now,
and start doing that other thing
that I'm daydreaming about.
You have to enjoy the work.
You have to enjoy the process.
And so, if you've picked a
business where you don't,
that's when you quit.
When people ask me, "Should
I quit on my business?"
Depends.
Do you still enjoy it?
Do you love it?
Do you have the passion for it?
That's the only thing that matters.
If you don't enjoy it,
and you're just chasing the goal, quit.
Right now, and move on to something else.
But if you do enjoy it,
and you want to keep going,
and you have this vision
of yourself in the future,
having this big impact,
then you have to keep going.
And you're going to get
hit with a lot of bricks
along the way, but you have to keep going
because you enjoy the work.
So the question of the day today is
I want to spread a
little bit of positivity.
I'm curious, what do you enjoy the most
about the process in your business?
What's your most favorite task?
Leave it down in the comments below.
Really curious to find out.
And if you leave a comment within
the first few hours of
this video going live,
you get a chance to win one
of two of our daily prizes.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Steph Reveron.
Steph, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your one Word, and taking that picture,
and sharing it with me.
It really, really means a lot to me,
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is,
much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning,
for another shot
of entpresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
(typewriter sounds)
- This is where trainers mess people up.
I've had trainers who
totally just want to prove
that you can never do what they do.
- Yeah.
- And they have you paying.
- Right.
- I know what you mean.
- Just to say like, "Oh, this poor guy."
- You're not as good as me.
- Right.
- And they go to blast
you, like they want you ...
Unless you're in pain and
you feel like you're sick,
and you're throwing up, they're like,
"Yeah, that's a workout, now.
Look at you, yeah, you
hurt, you can't walk, great.
- Yeah.
- And the whole point
it, what I tell people
is treat the gym like a spa.
The first time you ever go,
just go in there and walk around.
- Yeah.
- Touch the weights,
get a drink of water,
walk around, and then leave.
- Right.
- And I mean literally,
do that for like a week, two weeks,
until you just get to the
habit of getting in that door.
Because what's going
to happen is eventually
you're going to start lifting,
because you're there.
- Yeah.
- And you're going to do something.
And then you stop.
Don't ever get to the
point where you're like,
"I can't feel my arm."
It doesn't work.
People want ... they want
my body, and all this stuff,
but I've been working out consistently
since I was 14 years old.
- Right.
- And I'm 44, 30 years ...
- 30 years.
- ... of hard core, 2 hour workouts.
30 years.
- Yeah.
- So it doesn't happen overnight.
- Nope.
- You just have to enjoy the process.
- Totally.
- Learn to enjoy it, because
I'm sure there was a point
where you started to
enjoy losing 113 pounds.
- Yup, yup, yup.
- And that's the only way
you're going to keep going.
- Let's enjoy the journey.
Not the destination.
A lot of us delay our happiness.
When I get to this level,
when I get my degree,
when I get the kids, when I get married,
I'm going to be happy.
Enjoy the journey, enjoy the whole step,
the whole process.
Every day that you get up
to strive for whatever
it is that you're after.
You know I'm a goal oriented guy.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- But you don't celebrate when
you get to the finish line,
celebrate all along the way.
Celebrate all along the way.
- [Steve] Yeah man.
- A lot of time I'll bring
a friend of mine to the gym.
And let's say it's a girl
I'll bring out to the gym,
and she already feels
really hot about herself.
But as she goes to the gym,
she begins to see her weak spots.
She begins to actually
realize how far she has to go.
And paradoxically, the very act
of actually improving herself,
makes her makes her
feel even more insecure.
You'll see the same thing
when guys actually try to get
a little bit of money going.
Or let's say that they try to learn
to be good with girls, right?
Let's say you actually
thought your money was okay,
and then you start improving
your cash situation,
all of a sudden you realize,
damn if I want to get
a good business going,
or if I want to get my career
going with some good momentum,
I've a lot further to go than I realized.
Likewise, as far as girls go.
Most guys actually walk
around thinking like
they can win any fight,
they can pick up any girl.
But when you actually go try to do it,
and you realize how much you suck,
It winds up making you
feel even more insecure.
So, just remember that the fact
that you are trying to improve yourself,
it's a paradox between self-improvement
and self-acceptance,
because the very act
of improving yourself,
sometimes can make you
feel a little bit bad.
What's the frame that I come from then?
How do I do all the self-improvement stuff
and not feel terrible?
Well, what I do is I
come from a basic frame,
and the basic frame is,
I am already awesome,
and I'm just enjoying my journey
of becoming even more awesome.
So I remember back when I
was first teaching bootcamps,
One of the first ones I ever taught
was here in New York City.
I didn't really have a lot of students,
We didn't charge a lot of money,
And I probably wasn't the best teacher,
so you might not have wanted
to been at that bootcamp.
But the point being was,
I was teaching bootcamp in a Starbucks.
You know, I'd sneak in to an HIV clinic,
and say that I had HIV,
or we'd break into a school building,
and do it on milk crates.
I'd be doing seminars
in those environments.
And if you would've asked me
if I thought what I was doing was cool,
I'd say yeah, it's cool.
Right now, I might teach a
4-500 person seminar at a hotel.
You ask me if I think it's cool,
I say it's cool.
Someday I could be teaching
a 5,000 person audience
in a big auditorium somewhere,
like somewhere, you
know, convention center,
and if you ask me if I think it's cool,
I think that's cool.
And if I was running
the whole damn planet,
I'd think that's cool too.
Where I am on my journey,
I'm loving it, okay.
I love the journey.
Because, as far as I'm concerned,
the golden era is now.
The golden era is the present moment.
And wherever I am, right,
if you're asking me now,
"Oh, did it suck when
you taught the programs
back at Starbucks?"
No, it was awesome.
I was already awesome,
and enjoying my journey
to become even more awesome, right.
And someday if I'm teaching 5,000 people,
you say, "Oh, teaching 500 people,
was that too small of a crowd for you?"
I'd say, "No, I was just
enjoying my journey,
I was awesome, I was just enjoying
being on the path to
becoming even more awesome.